hi everyone I'm here I've just spent the
day at the KATUSA primary school which
is the first primary school that's cool
for life built here and I'm here not
just by myself I'm here with Jennifer
and also Roberts and can you introduce
yourselves for everyone back in
Australia hi Australia my name is
Jennifer I was in Australia a few month
ago I am the director of school for life
schools Becky a new ganja and with
Robert my name is Robert Hamme the head
teacher of Catoosa famous hood which was
the first school to be built by school
for life in Uganda all right so as
director Jennifer is responsible for all
three of the schools the one here at
KATUSA which as Robin mentioned it was
built first but it was built gradually
wasn't it what did it start it started
with one Brook and then later like the
following year we had more four
classrooms with brandy
that's that's great so it started off
with two classrooms and added on more
and now it's over 300 students isn't it
how many how many classes is that we are
having nine classes altogether mmm that
is from seven primary classrooms and
then two for nursery why fantastic and
we started you started the nursery a bit
later what was the reason why you
decided the nursery would be helpful for
the school ah I think the director of
schools can but then we saw that it was
more important for a child to start
education at the early stages of three
years because that stage is very
important for a child to start school so
that is why we started that easy D which
we call the early childhood education
center later on right so I think
probably something that people in
Australia wouldn't maybe understand is
here we're in a very we're in a very
rural area that's actually one of the
reasons why you chose to build here and
so would it be fair to say
virtually all of the parents of our
children here would be farmers would
that be correct yes their subsistence
farmers yes so therefore the families
around here very few of themselves maybe
went to school or maybe just very early
school probably most them would not
speak English
no no so they only speak up Uganda which
is the local language here
and for that reason you know if they are
not literate they can't speak English as
soon as the children have been here oh
maybe a few years they are more literate
and speak definitely speak better
English than their parents so children
are going to come to this school and
they don't have that background from
home yes they don't have parents who are
going to be able to educate them and
that's why having ECD is so helpful here
exactly okay so Robert you tell us a bit
about where are we walking right now
where are we going are we are going to
visit one of our homes where our
students come from so that we can look
at maybe that they are family background
as siblings and parents and we are
possible intervene they it have been
with their parent ask them some
questions how they are raising this
child how does a child sleep how that I
shall do homework and if there any
assistance that the parents give the kid
when doing homework right so is it it's
probably accurate to say that now that
KATUSA is the school has been here for
how many years now eighty eight years
it really is actually quite a
substantial part of the community and
all of the different families who live
here like you even have that that water
pump and that's something which is for
the entire community not just the school
- yeah right and what other ways and you
are telling me earlier today that you
actually have to understand what needs
the community has and then you actually
you and the other teachers reach out
into the community to try and help them
with that can you tell me about some of
those things this morning as I was
talking - I told you that we do
community outreach whereby we have
programs like raising voices we site out
communities and for instance find out
what they are need if their need is
maybe it's inside them about child right
we move on a theme of child rights we go
through drama and drama and a likely
other means that would attract the
attention so we dramatized with my
pontus of for essence having good
children rights and how to protect the
children at home even on the way to
school and if we find that maybe the
challenge is family violence we go on a
theme of violence to educate them why
they shouldn't violate either their
children or their wives or their husband
well yeah so it's it's really you know
after this many years it's having I
think it's pretty fair to say a very
substantial impact on the way that the
whole community interacts even with
itself you know it actually has an
impact Jennifer you've been here since
the beginning you know some of the staff
have just come on because the secondary
school was just built but you've been
here since the start what's one of the
hardest things that you had to deal with
in starting a school from scratch what
was difficult I had to deal with a lot
but some of these we came into an area
where parents themselves were not
educated and there was a lot of domestic
abuse domestic violence there was a lot
of child abuse violence basically so I
had to deal with the teaching of the
child in class when also teaching the
community itself the importance of
education the importance of a child
staying in school and also like the
gender-based violence issues where
parents believed in a girl child would
only go to school up to primary fund and
send them off for marriage mmm so I had
to come in we had to come in and step
into that and sensitize parents and show
them the importance it was not really an
easy job but we are still moving on I
would say we are at least 80 percent
successful mmm yeah that's fantastic now
I I really wanted to introduce you to
Robert and Jennifer they're doing such
incredible work here and it's also
really important that everyone back home
understands that this is not it's not as
though people coming from outside the
country can come in and say we know what
this country needs we know how to fix
this community
it really has to be the locals who
understand the issues and also how to be
culturally sensitive about giving them
the help that they need not to mention
the fact that because people in the
community don't speak English someone
like me would not be very useful out
here but we're gonna be finishing our
walk into this village shortly it's
certainly by no means one of the
farthest villages that the children walk
from because I have to go back home
after this so we got to finish the walk
back but this just gives you a sense I
mean if you have a look at this this
area in front of us turn around so you
can see where we're walking we just
started going down this step path and
people are these are sort of what the
dwellings look like and you know it
definitely is a far cry from kind of
what most people in Australia think of
when they think I walk to school this is
a very different kind of premise so I
hope you've gained a bit of insight or a
big thank you to Robert and Jennifer for
me so welcome and and our little friends
over here say hi and yeah thanks for
watching I'll see you guys soon and I've
got lots more to share because the work
here in you're gonna need a lot of
support you know it was a challenge to
start these schools but there are still
many challenges yeah to be faced so
thanks guys talk to you soon